right bob so we're sitting where you
made your most recent album i hope at
some point we can get a full shot of
where we are because i've never seen
anything like this
um
when did you make this album
um we got this studio done brought
everything down from uh my michigan
studios
right before i hit the fan code
yeah so how did you spend covet right
here writing and recording had more time
to work on this album than
since my first breakthrough album double
without a cause you know you spend years
with that first album yeah and then from
there it's just a rat race of getting
more records out when you hit a lick and
you're successful in this record having
a couple years just to fine-tune every
lyric and every note and leave some
stuff raw and that feel like that and
see what works what does it to keep
going back to the drawing board was just
you know a luxury that i haven't been
afforded in a long time and
you know you say in every album everyone
does this is my best album yeah
of course sell sell but you know it
really is you know that i i in my heart
i know it's uh one of my best efforts in
a long time definitely since rock and
roll jesus you've been doing this 30
years but you still
bring intensity to it like how often do
you come here well i'm workaholic i'm
here at on an average day 3 30 in the
morning monday through friday
and i'm usually the last one out about
six o'clock at night
in the studio yeah well i'm here from
yeah 3 30 in the morning i'm
writing doing things checking emails my
head works best in the morning i love to
write then and work on music and then
about 7 a.m my buddy comes in we play
some pickleball you know do a little
cardio
they get back people start showing up at
9 30 i love that time in the morning i
get to myself and then you know my
engineer gets here about 9 30 we record
all day grandpa gets this little nap in
the afternoon and
[Laughter]
groundhog day do it again monday monday
through friday then friday afternoon
things are feeling good like crack of
beer in the afternoon have a big time
friday and saturday relaxing sunday get
back to it
that's amazing so you're i mean a rock
star with accounting hours
yeah
yeah rockstar i play one on tv pretty
well
that's just interesting
so there's like a lot of discipline
around it yeah this doesn't happen
without discipline you know people only
see the wild side usually and yeah the
party side and hopefully some of the you
know charitable things and things i've
done through the years there's both
sides out there but uh
that's the other day i worked my ass off
and that's that's when people ask me for
advice i'm like i work harder than you
that's what happened
so what was the idea behind this album
um i kind of came together at the end by
calling a bad reputation you know for a
real good time because i pretty much
sums me up
you know it's everything i just wanted
to go back a little bit to my roots of
the hard rock and hard wrap
you know heavier stuff but i also want
to throw in the tinges of you know
southern rock and and country music and
soul music and of course rock and roll
all which i love you know so much and
have really honed my craft over the
years to
you know not just be fluent in one but
you know touch on them all at you know
what my family and friends and fans feel
like i do at a pretty good level so if
there was i mean
a message behind the album what would it
be
uh to my fans i love you dearly to you
critics haters and trolls go yourself
it's that's pretty clear in the office
like you're not kind of hiding that
message right i have the things i do is
like
you know to solidify my fans and like
i'll i'll say a lot this is my friends
family fans that's really all that
matters to me but i love the trolls and
the haters and the critics who've been
trying to you know knock me down for 20
30 years and i just i'm still standing
still operating at the highest levels
and so sometimes i do things perfectly
purposefully
just to kind of be a wise ass or look
like a little bit of a just because my
fans will get the tongue and cheek in
the front it and
the people that hate me will just go god
damn it
he'll just piss him off more so why
haven't you been canceled like people
aren't allowed to say what they think
you are i am uncancelable why is that
because i don't give up
and i'm not in bed with any big
corporate things at the end of the day
there's nobody i'm beholden to no record
companies no corporate interests no
nothing and you can't cancel me i love
it when they try i'm like yeah
why aren't there more artists like that
because they're in bed with record
companies and you know corporate deals
and instructors at every level and
you know it's um and if someone finds a
way to get me a little bit here and
there i'll find another way around it
you never see artists talk like that
they seem very easy to intimidate
at what point did you realize like
you're just not gonna be intimidated
day one really i think i crawled out of
the womb with both middle fingers in the
air
and that wasn't anything a lot of it you
know is
you know there's a little fun in there
to kind of you know yeah be rock and
roll and be the bad guy and this that
and the other because you know my
heart's big at the end of the day and i
have a lot of love and respect for
anybody that shows that back to me
but you know grandpa don't play no mess
either do the other guys in your
business ever say to you like man i wish
i could say exactly what i think all the
time
every day
really every day especially the country
guys yeah because they got to be
understandably careful like you know the
awards and things
radio corporate interests they mean a
lot in country music the award stuff
actually helped them out and rock and
roll it's like hey you're getting award
for this it's like tell them
i can't care less about their awards you
don't want any more awards
i've never played any of those games
anyway you must have watched a lot of
people sort of float off
into the atmosphere in here a lot of
them come and go you know same old
stories you know we've all seen the
behind the music well that's the same
story that's what i'm saying so how do
you avoid that
i i just have a sense of discipline when
things you know are getting too out of
hand whether it was back in the day with
drugs and alcohol they're saying you
gotta go like what's important they need
to reel this in
you know and eventually you know certain
agents cut some things out and like you
know focus on what you love you know
your friends your family music you know
what's important in life you only got so
much time you know let's make the most
of that time let's not waste it who are
your fans do you have a psych picture of
who they are
yeah hard-working
hard-working folks that love to have a
good time yeah
do you hear from him
yeah absolutely
you can't not hear from people these
days
that's a really good point you're trying
to tune it out doesn't happen so do you
feel like you've got a pretty good sense
of what they think
yeah they seem to think a lot of the
things i do not everything nobody's
views a line right i'm not opposed to
anybody's opposing views a lot of
friends you know that we're still
friends who are
left a little farther than that on some
things i love getting together with them
and cutting it up having a couple beers
and talking about things and here on
both sides you know i think that's
important so you're going on tour where
are you going
um
a lot of midwest and south a little east
coast and some select dates on the west
coast um
america i don't go outside i don't show
passport too much you don't why you've
been all around the world you don't i
just have no interest
and i you know i i get why some bands do
this that in the other and if i wanted
to be
the biggest deal in every country in the
world i could but i'm like
i like my own bed i'm big in kentucky
man
and that's good enough in fact that's so
you're not playing venues that require
vex cards
no and it was no you know of course yeah
that's what the headline ran from from
the left you know like get rock said and
i'm like great it's on my tour for me go
for it
there was gonna be no vax carts by the
time we toured anyway it was common
knowledge anybody with half a brain knew
that yeah so you know the only place we
did that we decided not to play was
buffalo new york because new york was
looked like it probably could have
something in place you know where you
have to wear a mask or show a card or
whatever and i was like
no i'm not no
that's why because it's stupid
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else